it's collapse rocked the crypto trading
Community now the former boss of trading
platform FTX is facing criminal charges
Sam bankman freed has denied knowingly
committing fraud now that claim could be
tested in the U.S courts
from the Pinnacle to the pit
sambachman freed the disgraced crypto
Tycoon was arrested in the Bahamas at
the request of the United States seeking
to charge him after the spectacular
collapse of his cryptocurrency platform
FTX
the 30 year old crypto celebrity became
an object of attention last month as he
suddenly filed for bankruptcy as FTX
suffered the liquidity crunch
the company left more than a million
clients unable to access their funds
the liquidity to Crunch was caused by
FTX users pulling 6 billion dollars from
the platform in three days
and it came after Bank manfred's
secretly moved 10 billion dollars worth
of FTX customer funds to another one of
his companies called Alameda research
through a digital backdoor
at least one billion of that has
reportedly vanished completely finally
on November 11th FTX filed for
bankruptcy protection and magma Fritz
stepped down as chief executive the
United States Securities and Exchange
Commission has charged bankman freed
with orchestrating a scheme to defraud
investors
Bank Manfred has previously apologized
to customers but said he doesn't
personally think he has any criminal
liability
well let's discuss the collapse of FTX
and arrest of sambangman freed with
Nicholas Day from coindesk and actually
Nicholas coindesk did some crucial
reporting on this story so it's good to
get to speak to you about it when did
the problems with FDX begin
hi thanks for having me
um you know arguably ftx's problems have
been kind of baked in since its
foundation based on some of the public
filings that we've seen and some of the
allegations we're seeing from
authorities where FTX just allowed its
sister company Alameda to borrow funds
which turned out to be customer funds
which uh Alameda was unable to pay back
leaving a pretty massive hole on ftx's
balance sheet but kind of you know more
specifically uh this entire story kind
of happened over the last month or so
where FTX went from being this you know
massive Titan of Industry to being this
company going through bankruptcy
yeah the Alameda Revelations are what
sort of led to the collapse but we've
just seen John Ray the current Uh
current CEO even uh testifying before
Congress and he read out a long list of
things that they've since discovered
that was wrong with FTX how was a
company that was so big and handling so
many people's money able to be
mismanaged so badly
a big part of it seems to be uh that FTX
was controlled by a fairly small group
of people who just didn't really engage
apparently in some standard practices
for bookkeeping for governance there
wasn't really a central you know board
of directors or anything like that to
oversee the main FTX entity there wasn't
much in the way of documentation uh
so these are just some of the
allegations that have been made in
recent weeks but
um it sure seems like what happened was
FTX went from you know being this kind
of brand new company when it was founded
to you know growing rapidly to you know
being this multi-billion dollar
multinational entity while maintaining
the exact same practices that it had as
a startup uh one of the allegations that
you know Mr Ray made in the house
Financial Services Committee hearing
today was they were using QuickBooks
they you know fairly unsophisticated
retail piece of software for its entire
bookkeeping purposes which is yeah not
not something you would expect from a
massive entity
yeah it's almost as if the the business
outgrew the people that were were
running it isn't it but has the ins uh
you know this this case with FTX has it
shaken the confidence of of crypto
Traders is there not fear that there are
other fdx's out there
I think there definitely is a major fear
of that now one of the biggest things
about FTX is that it had gone for months
and years saying we are the reliable
company we are safe we are something
people can trust and a lot of people
took them at the word so you know right
now the fact that we're looking at a
bankruptcy where there could be
potentially over a million customers who
need you know have lost access to their
funds not to mention the other companies
that kept their own funds on FTX
assuming FTX would be safe uh the
ramifications are huge there is
definitely a lot more scrutiny I think
of other crypto companies like FTX and a
lot more question they are a lot more
um you know uncertainty about whether or
not these companies are indeed safe for
consumers
is going to be fascinating to watch
where this goes next Nicholas Day from
cointest thank you so much for bringing
us that story
I want to bring in Stephen Ehrlich now
he is director of digital assets
research at Forbes he joins me from New
York Stephen it's good to have you with
us I want to make sure I've got this
correct you interviewed bankman freed of
this week and he was reportedly prepared
to testify before a U.S congressional
committee today before the arrest took
place is that correct
yes that's correct and thanks for having
me I've I've interviewed uh Mr Beckman
freed multiple times and I did interview
him yesterday morning Eastern time for
about an hour in what I believe to be is
his final interview uh as a free man at
least for quite some time I mean you
interviewed him and he wasn't sitting
there with his attorneys now that he's
been arrested we can assume that his
willingness to be so candid with people
that that's over what was the impression
that you got from him was he aware of
the gravity of events that he was at the
helm of
that's an interesting question it's it's
hard to tell I mean sometimes when you
start hearing numbers like 32 billion
dollars which was uh the company ftx's
highest valuation based on its most
recent fundraising round uh it kind of
gets abstract from from reality
abstracted from reality uh in truth
because the company had about a million
customers it has a debt of about eight
to ten billion dollars and when he gets
asked about his his legal Jeopardy and I
asked him about that at the very end of
our interview yesterday he he keeps
saying that or he kept saying that it's
about the customers I'm not worried
about my own fate but at the same time
there are some indications that that he
was aware of the Jeopardy that he was in
uh for instance he hinted in a question
that I asked him about why he resigned
he suggested that he was getting
pressure from from legal counsel and it
was indicated to him that if he resigned
it might make things a little bit easier
from a legal perspective uh he was ready
to testify as you asked previously he he
put together about 18 pages of testimony
that he was going to submit before the
house Financial Services committee and
and he most he recently switched legal
counsel again because I think he
understood the Jeopardy the legal
Jeopardy that he was in uh but at the
same time he's always been a master at
using the press to kind of build his
image and I think he felt that for as
long as he was free he was going to try
to do that as much as possible you know
based on what you heard in the
interviews that you've conducted do you
think that maybe the authorities made a
mistake in arresting him when they did
today maybe they should have let him
testify first
that isn't another interesting question
because I know that Maxine Waters the
the chair of the house Financial
Services committee
um said yesterday she was disappointed
that they're not going to be able to
hear
um Mr Bachman Freud's testimony uh in
front of uh in front of the committee
today and it's just uh current CEO John
Ray there uh so I mean I mean I I think
that there is some benefit to hearing
him uh testify but at the same time uh
he's he has been very public he has
given uh more than a dozen interviews
and and frankly in many cases he gets to
ask the same questions where is the
money why were there such poor financial
controls uh where are the audited
financial statements and and he he keeps
giving the same answers uh things like I
don't have access to the data I'm trying
to to this is my answer from the best of
my recollection so and so forth uh
wholly unsatisfying answers so
um well yes it's always great to have as
much transparency as possible it's hard
to imagine that he was going to give any
major revelations in front of the
committee because the of the legal
Jeopardy that I'm sure he knew he was in
well Stephen unfortunately we're out of
time but please come back and talk with
us again because I have a feeling that
this investigation also in this case is
going to last a long time Stephen eilish
with Forbes thank you Steve
great thank you